all right bladesmiths Welcome to our
strength test today is the wooden crate
shop I'm going to take each of your
blades and attempt 10 strikes through
this wooden crate it's going to test the
overall durability of your knife edge
holding and we're going to see not what
your blades can do to this crate but
with a crate can do to your blades
chilling you're up first you ready yes
sir let's have some fun
my Blade's a lot heavier than my
competitors so I think it's going to
perform real well let it rip Tater chip
I'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
should do
just a few little things
right in here in your choil that's sharp
I'd like to see that taken down
narrowing down here would have made a
little more comfortable too swinging
something this big and heavy you want to
have as much control as possible
contouring with that Palm swell in there
it's a big help in holding a wheel in
this knife no damage to the edge or
anything nicely done
Rachel you ready I'm ready all right
let's do it
I actually feel pretty good but you
really just never know in the knife
making World anything can happen this is
the moment you separate dogs and the
puppies
[Music]
wow
oh my God you okay I'm high on life
right now
well Rachel you lost that little flake
there
nothing else seems to have opened up
biggest problem I have with this knife
is the balance there's a lot of weight
up here there's not a lot of knife to
support that tip and whenever I strike
on a crate it's actually smashing into
me in the webbing in the hand right
there
your Edge is good though it's still
Sharp
held up nicely good job thank you Buster
how you feeling
insecure now
let's do it
and Jay picks at the man now I'm
thinking I know there's a lot of flaws
in my blade so I just don't know what's
going to happen I'm nervous right now
[Music]
Buster we've got a crack going from
spine to Edge right where that thin spot
is how food it was
that is a serious malfunction right
there it's only being held in this
little belly of the clip and if we go to
straighten it for a sharpness test I
feel it's going to break off launch day
I'm sorry but for safety reasons we're
not going to be able to proceed to the
sharpness test for your knife
bladesmiths the tests here in the Forge
are designed to be intentionally brutal
for a reason not every bladesmith makes
a blade that can complete the tests
Buster unfortunately your weapon has
suffered catastrophic blade failure and
I have to ask you to please leave the
forge
I'm feeling very disappointed I just
can't prove to myself that I can compete
and that I was better than something
Rachel Sean congratulations your work on
your nautically themed blades have
propelled you into the final round of
this competition now we're sending you
back to your home for just for five days
to recreate an iconic weapon from
history that weapon is
the catching down
the catching down was the weapon of
choice for the catch-in tribe of Myanmar
known for the discipline fighting skills
to catch in people use this terrifying
Slaughter tool to decapitate their
enemies leading them to become one of
the most feared headhunting tribes in
the world
a sharp single-edged blade flares out to
a widened Square tip that delivers
lethal slashing blows
and proves to still be a deadly weapon
in popular television shows like
Spartacus or the dam
it must be an authentic working version
of this weapon you do this well and you
could walk away with ten thousand
dollars in a new title after five days
you'll return and present your place to
our panel of expert judges bon voyage
Blaze Smiths
okay
Sean Rachel welcome back to the forge
you've had five days at your home for is
to work on your catching Dows Sean how
did it go it went real well I chose the
5160 to forge my blade headset and
finished and the handle I did a canvas
record is it a ten thousand dollar blade
yes sir I do believe so
Rachel how'd it go for you it was
interesting say the least I ended up
going with the leaf spring I stuck with
my repurposing Mantra and used a table
leg for a handle and did a hamper wrap I
feel like it's a ten thousand dollar
weapon I feel it is
well blade Smiths your weapons will now
be put through a series of brutal tests
they're designed this way to set your
weapons apart from one another up first
is the kill test Doug
the gachandal was used to battle the
jungles in Burma it was also a weapon
used to give them the title of
Headhunters to see what kind of damage
your catching dolls will do I will take
your weapon to deliver a slashing blows
of this ballistics level shot on your
first you ready yes sir let's do this
there's a lot of things that could
happen when they go through the test a
small chip failure and I'm just thinking
the whole time oh my God
[Music]
there's a job
well Sean initial contact in here
disemboweled this ballistics dummy
on a chop right here it definitely
chopped and cut all the way into the jaw
and the backhand swing you pretty much
chop this color open
the blade feels good in the hand
it lacerates it moves well
your weapon will kill
it's just like a big release is that
things have done everything that I
thought it would you put your mind to
something and you make it happen
Rachel's your turn you ready Friday's
over let's do this
coming out to testing really was like a
reality check and I just go oh man this
is the time where they get to say
whether I sink or swim
see
uh Rachel it's rattling
I gotta ask you what's your construction
with your handle that is a solid handle
and I did a wood pin and then I wrapped
it with rice glue okay rice glue so
there's no epoxy here I kept it
traditional with traditional adhesives
and then the three layers of hemp wrap
the fact that you have a wooden pin in
there and rice glue it shouldn't move is
traditional and it's moving and there's
a big concern whether it's going to stay
there
this competition first and foremost is
always about safety first
and the kind of force that I want to
deliver over here is the kind of force
that I deliver to that
so I don't want to hold back for
fairness of testing and I have no
confidence that with everybody being
this close and the amount of delivery I
have to do on this done
it's a big safety issue
I'm really afraid that this life is
going to fly out I'm crushed I wanted
this weapon to be tested I want to see
what it could do but I didn't get enough
time to really test this thing and
here's the end result
Rachel Doug and the other judges have
issued me a vote of no confidence in
your weapons overall Construction
which means that we cannot test it
fairly compared to Sean's blade and
therefore your blade did not make the
cut and I have to ask you
to please leave the forge
my aim was historical accuracy but it
just came down to I did not use enough
rice glue my first time using it this
was a lot of Furs for me my next step
would be to make a were they catching
dough and I want to hang it on my wall I
got you catching though you know like
now we're even
Sean congratulations you are the forest
and fire champion and will be receiving
a check
for ten thousand dollars good job
thank you
[Applause]
weapon's definitely a killer how do you
feel I feel great I mean I would like to
see anything go through all the other
challenges but oh well I'm just tickled
to death well congratulations thank you
sir I'm very proud of what I've done
that's why I'm here you know
congratulations I won forged and fire
yeah baby
I like to have that head right there
there you go
[Laughter]